défi communiste ou communisants vérité
d'hommes semblables limbo
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopitone l'observatoire politique je
suis 2010 viel cofondatrice de scopeo et
je vous souhaite la bienvenue sur ce
troisième épisode de notre série
l'entrevue politique
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux de
se recevoir monsieur olivier al
mais avant toute chose je laisse la
parole à emilien prochain également
membre de scopeo pour qu'ils posent le
déportent le décor de ce podcast
et oui merci domitille bonjour à tous
ceux qui nous écoutent et surtout
bonjour à vous olivier pon
merci vous nous faites l'honneur
aujourd'hui de nous accorder cette
entrevue pour discuter d'un sujet sur
lequel vous êtes spécialiste qui est
celui de la religion islamique
il s'agit là d'un thème qui revient
fréquemment dans le débat public
français
nous non plus à l'heure des projets de
lois actuelles sur les séparatismes mais
avant tout avant de démarrer l'entrevue
mathieu anne je vous laisse vous
présenter
merci merci de votre invitation alors
donc moi je suis à l'origine au
médiéviste donc j'ai suivi tout une
forme et une formation tout à fait
classique en histoire médiévale latine
occidental et puis suit un parcours un
peu chaotique qui m'a mené en egypte
puis après en instituts coraniques en
france
g voilà je me suis initié à la langue
arabe
j'ai été diplômée en langues arabe et
puis forcément je me suis initié à
l'islamologie et donc depuis une
quinzaine d'années en parallèle à mes
travaux de l'histoire médiévale
je poursuis des travaux de recherche sur
la question de l'islamologie est donc ce
qui m'amène à enseigner dans plusieurs
établissements supérieurs puisque vous
êtes initié la langue arabe
beaucoup de termes et de concepts liés à
l'islam soit employé à tort et certains
d'entre eux ont une traduction
approximative en français donc avant
toute chose et puisque ces concepts sont
fondamentaux pour bien comprendre
l'islam et qu'ils seront sans doute
utilisé au cours de cet entretien
pourriez-vous nous rappeler ce que sont
le diable et la charia je vois que déjà
vous orienter le débat de façon musclée
alors dans dans le coran l'expression
jihad
on a rappelé à son signifie l'effort ou
le zèle lorsque dans le coran le terme
djihad sur se trouve telle qu'elle
signifie zèle ou efforts lorsque il est
associé un autre formule qu'on appelle
s'intitule jihadi fille s'habille landa
c'est à dire l'effort ou le zèle dans le
sentier de dieu dans le chemin de dieu
ou pour la cause de dieu
lorsqu'on trouve cette formule complète
jihadi fi sabil a alors le contexte est
toujours militaire mais toujours lié à
une demande de combat contre
l'infidélité l'impiété la peau stasi
et c'est donc le mot djihad seul ne
signifie rien de partir mans militaires
l'expression jihadi fiable et là
effectivement à une dimension
explicitement en militaires mais ce qui
pourrait passer pour une obligation tout
à fait clair et explicite dans le coran
en fait ne l'est pas tant que ça parce
que finalement à part de réclamer un
combat contre l'impunité
le corps va pas tellement plus loin et
c'est pour ça que par la suite les
intellectuels musulmans notamment à
partir du huitième neuvième siècle sont
allés chercher toute une série de textes
qui aurait été prononcée par le prophète
lui-même je vais l'appeler le prophète
un pendant tout cet entretien pour des
raisons de commodité de langage
eh bien on est allé chercher des textes
ou des déclarations quand elle fait le
prophète déclaration qu'on appelle les
abysses et dans déclarations qui vont
loin dans la le détail que ne le fait le
camp donc on a le texte coranique qui
reste finalement flou sur cette
injonction du combat à contre
l'infidélité et on a des textes
prophétiques qui eux sont beaucoup plus
précis jusqu'à former un chapitre
complet de manuel dadis est où là il ya
un grand nombre de détails et sur cette
injonction impératif qui est le combat
contre la mécréance on voyait que en
fait il ya plusieurs étapes historiques
chronologique dans la construction de ce
qu'est le jihad et au moment des grands
qu'on va entre le califat islamique et l
empire byzantin ces éléments qui
puissent dans le coran qui sont
précisées dans les radis ce voyage à
nouveau et encore plus précise et dans
la jurisprudence islamique et dans des
textes qui sont à peu près finalement de
la fin du neuvième siècle jusqu'à
l'époque des croisades
il ya eu par la suite un développement
ultérieur sur ce qu'est le djihad com
il faut le mener contre eux qu'ils faut
le mener et dans quelles conditions il
faut le donc on ne peut pas s'appuyer
uniquement sur le coran pour définir ce
qu'est le diable
il faut toute la tragédie tout la
tradition intérieur ça c'était pour le
premier le deuxième terme ces salaires
en arabe charia c'est la voix la voix la
voix
sous-entendu la voix prophétique le
modèle prophétique finalement la charia
s'est constitué comme corpus juridique
très tardivement finalement pas avant le
neuvième siècle et la charia est devenu
progressivement l'ensemble des exigences
juridiques quotidienne individuelles et
collectives qui gouverne la communauté
musulmane
cette charia s'appuie sur plusieurs
sources le coran bien évidemment
s'appuie sur les radicelles prophète
autre source majeure mais aussi elle
laisse la possibilité d'une adaptation
de ses dessous pour céder exigence
morale éthique et juridique de ces deux
sources
et cette adaptation est permise par un
procédé qu'on appelle ici yade c'est à
dire l'interprétation et donc l'ensemble
la charia c'est un ensemble des
obligations ou des parce que dès les
conseils sociaux individuels qui crée la
moralité qui crée le comportement
quotidien du croyant et de la communauté
est donc basé sur trois sources
différentes parfois contradictoires le
coran les indices et les ch'tis yade et
est donc cette charia a été mise en
place finalement c'est le moment où
cette charia est entièrement défini on
peut dire que c'est à peu près la fin du
neuvième siècle d'accord merci pour ces
quelques précisions
trompe pas vous allez publier
prochainement un ouvrage qui s'intitule
l'europe face à l'islam histoire croisée
de deux civilisations a vraiment de nous
focaliser davantage sur le cas de
l'islam en france
pouvez vous nous rappeler quand et
comment s'est opérée le rapproche toi le
rapprochement entre ces deux
civilisations que sont l'europe
chrétienne et la civilisation islamique
oui alors il ya un premier premier
rapprochement 6 puis en tout cas une
première mise en relation qui évidemment
celle de l'affrontement
c'est à dire que le monde islamique qui
est en train de partir du viiie siècle
de s'étendre grâce aux conquérants
arabes parvient aux portes de l'europe
appelant 710 lorsque plusieurs groupes
arabo-berbères traversent le détroit de
gibraltar et à partir de 711 l'espagne
qui était gouvernée par une monarchie
wisigothique l'espagne tombe sous le
contrôle de cette nouvelle nouvelle
force qui est qui et quel islam
c'est une force sa foi religieuse et
c'est une force aussi politique de deux
éléments majeurs en tout cas au début
donc quasiment la moitié de la péninsule
ibérique tombent sous le coup de cette
conquête au même moment
byzance est menacée départ trois fois
d'un siège extrêmement dures de la part
de ses congas de la part de ses
concurrents et autres éléments qui crée
évidemment si le choc
en tout cas cette rencontre entre
guillemets c'est l'effondrement des
provinces byzantine d'orient où se
trouvait en majorité des chrétiens est
donc évidemment tout cela finit par être
connus en europe occidentale les
conquêtes en orient les menaces sur
byzance et la conquête la conquête de
l'espagne alors en réalité le problème
c'est que ces conquêtes les sources
européennes qui datent du huitième et
dix neuvième siècle ont bien du mal à
identifier ce qu'est cet ennemi parce
que là
mention religieuse cet ennemi même si
elle transparaît dans les chroniques et
dans les sources
en réalité elle paraît toujours
secondaire ce qui est toujours premier
dans la définition de cette nouvelle
force qui vient d'en qui vient de
pénétrer en europe c'est le fait que
c'est une nation c'est une ethnie les
chroniqueurs imagine les musulmans
d'abord comme un peuple et c'est pour ça
qu'il ne les appelle pas les musulmans
il les appelle les sarrasins nos
sarrasin ou fait renvoie aux arabes
entre guillemets donc s'il y avait ni
cet ennemi c'est d'abord un peu et il
s'avère effectivement que ce peuple est
un peuple qui professent un culte on a
du mal à identifier
parfois les chroniques disent que ce
sont des païens hier donc dans des
adorateurs animiste où ils delattre et
certaines sources disent que ce sont des
hérétiques tiers des chrétiens qui ne
suivent pas là la doctrine officielle
que ce soit en orient ou en occident est
donc en fait on ne sait pas les
identifier ce qui est assez étonnant
c'est que même des récits de latin qui
reviennent d'orient apparemment il ya
quand même beaucoup de pèlerinage à
jérusalem au 9e siècle au 10ème siècle
il y en a un peu moins parce que les
routes sont moins sûrs 11e siècle à
cause de l'arrivée des turcs mais
finalement jusqu'au début du 11e siècle
il ya beaucoup de pèlerins qui vont qui
vont en orient et à leur retour certains
écrivent des chroniques ou écrivains des
récits de voyage et bien ce qui est très
étonnant c'est qu'ils décrivent dans les
temples sarrazin donc en fait les
mosquées ils disent que les gens adorent
des dieux adore des statuts or il est à
peu près évident qu'il n'ya jamais une
statue de culte dans les mosquées de
syrie d'orient et c est donc ce qu'est
ce qui est déstabilisant c'est que les
européens qui voyage en orient et qui
connaissent ou en tout cas qui sont
confrontés à la religion musulmane mais
en fait son âme n'est dit
certaine manière à aa à gauchir leur
propre regard à transformer leurs
propres je suis allé dans un temple
païen les musulmans sont des païens donc
j'ai forcément vu le statut de culte en
plein milieu de la mosquée assez
étonnant donc le premier vecteur de
connaissance de rencontres de l'islam à
cesser l'affrontement
après il y aura d'autres vecteurs
notamment les échanges commerciaux
intellectuelle ou autre mais c'est vrai
qu'au début c'est quand même d'abord un
affrontement et mais il y a un deuxième
élément qu'on identifie souvent très
très peu très très mal c'est que 1 d un
premier point commun au tout début de
cette rencontre c'est que l'islam
partagent finalement del viiie siècle
avec l'europe
quelques éléments communs et c'est
notamment le rapport à la grèce c'est à
dire que à la fin du viiie siècle
lesquels pif abbassides lancent un
mouvement d'intérêt vis-à-vis de la
grèce la grèce antique j'entende ce qui
a donné naissance entre à peu près les
années 800 et les années 900 à toute une
série de traduction de textes de textes
grecs vers le syriaque vers l'arabe et c
est donc c'est ça qui est très étonnant
c'est que au moment où l'islam met en
place son système juridique met en place
la charia met en place toutes ces
sources
mais définitivement par écrit les
hadiths du prophète et impose une seule
version du camp au même moment ce monde
musulman se tourner vers la grèce la
grèce antique et vers des textes
philosophiques des textes géométriques
les textes médicaux texte qui
intéressait eux aussi les européens donc
souvent on dit finalement oui les
sources sont pas du tout les mêmes la
manière dont les deux civilisations
s'ils sont constitués sont complètement
différentes
c'est en grande partie vrai mais il faut
pas oublier quand même qu' il ya eu des
sources communes
notamment l'héritage grec en est une
finalement l'autre élément à st
intéressant qu'on néglige parfois c'est
la question de l' empire romain la
puissance de l'empiré romain la
puissance de l'empereur romain et est ce
qu'on appelle parfois le césarisme ou l'
espèce de penser c'est harry liste qui
fait de l'empereur romain une divinité
une quasi divinité et bien beaucoup
attiré le califat notamment à l'époque
des abbassides d'avion à partir du viiie
siècle
à tel point que le califat qui était un
pouvoir qui n'avait rien de sacré au
sens propre du terme le khalife 1 les
premiers califes sont d'abord des hommes
politiques qui certes mène les victoires
de l'islam mais c'est l'heure voire est
d'abord un pouvoir politique
eh bien on a l'impression que l'
influence de la puissance du sentiment
religieux romain vis à vis de l'emprunt
a été capté par les qualifs qui
effectivement à partir du huitième
neuvième siècle adopte des perspectives
presque de sacralisation du poids qui
correspond d'ailleurs assez assez bien
aussi ce qu'on appelle l'iran ni schalit
rendent chaque qui est l'autorité du roi
des rois perses qui avait un côté
théocratique aussi et on en fait la
dimension quasi théocratique du califat
n'est pas originellement encore année
elle est probablement imiter reprise
soit de la divinisation de l'empereur
romain soin de lire en chats persans
lanriec c'est intéressant en fait les
choses sont beaucoup nous vendent que ce
qu'on pense
merci beaucoup du fait de cette histoire
à la fois conflictuelles et en même
temps tu de ce rapprochement
intellectuelle on peut se poser la
question aujourd'hui est ce que la
république française laïque est
compatible avec l'islam et est ce qu
elle peut s'imposer à lui de la même
manière qu'elle s'est imposée au culte
catholique après la fois 2000 après la
loi de 1905 et pour un musulman
pratiquant
comment est-ce qui peut respecter à la
fois les règles du coran et ouais
d'accord alors eu le rapport entre une
république laïque et l'islam
la 7ème enfin cette question impose en
fait systématiquement de définir de
pontpoint si la république laïque laïque
ou père est d'abord un régime juridique
et politique
elle n'a donc pas de poids de
l'autorisation de pénétrer dans
l'intimité de l'individu c'est à dire
que la république est un ordre juridique
et dès lors que le citoyen respecte cet
ordre juridique et politique
sa conscience et garantit
c'est tout l'intérêt la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
celle aussi de 89 10 729 etc
il est clair que la république au sens
global du terme a très souvent eu la
tentation d'aller au delà de cette
simple obéissance de forme à sa loi ou
réclamé une obéissance du coeur et une
conviction du coeur c'était le cas
évidemment en 1793 ou une obéissance
purement externe ne suffit plus à la
république elle veut elle identifie des
suspects on sent bien que depuis
quelques années la république voudrait
être autre chose qu'un régime juridique
et politique notamment par des valeurs
de la république
on demande d'adhérer aux valeurs de la
république or en théorie les valeurs de
la république qui d'ailleurs ne sont
jamais défini une valeur renvoie à
l'intimité à une conviction personnelle
à une moralité un intérieur donc là ça
veut bien dire que quand on défend les
valeurs de la république sans jamais les
définir il ya une tentative d'une
manière ou d'une autre d'intrusion dans
la conscience humaine
c'est là où l'évolution récente est un
petit peu gênante quand même
voilà si la république est un régime
juridique et politique elle n'a pas à
adam enfin pénétrer dans l'intimité
dès lors islam ou pas islam l'individu
reste libre dans son coeur dans son âme
dans son esprit la république ne peut
donc pas demander dans ce cadre là que
on croit en elle comme on croit en dieu
de même que la conscience reste libre
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des acquis du
tribunal de nuremberg
c'est à dire que il y à la loi de la
conscience qui surpasse toutes les lois
humaines de toute façon donc avant même
de poser la question de l'islam
on est obligé de redéfinir finalement
c'est rémy on est obligé de redire ce
que c est surtout ce que ce que ça n'est
pas la république n'est pas un régime
qui autorise à pénétrer l'intimité des
fonctions dès lors le citoyen qu'ils
soient musulmans ou autres qui obéit à
la loi même en apparence même hypocrisie
et bien il est un citoyen comme un autre
contre lequel on n'a pas de pouls à lui
chercher dans les éléments et je ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point
l'islam est il compatible avec une
république qui justement ne
pénètreraient pas dans la conscience
individuelle
voilà encore ça dépend ce que vous
appelez vite cela si l'islam est un
culte une religion il est évident que ça
ne pose aucun problème pas plus de
problèmes qu avec le catholicisme
si l'islam est une civilisation et
l'islam est aussi une civilisation
évidemment les choses sont différentes
puisque qui dit civilisation dit corpus
intellectuels culturels politiques dits
des frontières ou en tout cas des zones
frontières dit d identité formés et
c'est pas bon
si on dit est ce que l'islam est
compatible en europe
à ce moment là ici pour vous l'islam
c'est une civilisation
en fait vous posez la question du
métissage des civilisations alors que
dans le premier cas si ça n'est qu'une
religion vous poser le problème de la
fusion
d'un culte dans un système établi laïc
républicain et ses week en fait selon
les éléments selon la manière dont vous
définissez les choses la réponse est pas
du tout la même
et il est clair que du côté musulman
aussi en fait on a un flou en permanence
sur les définitions et c'est bien normal
parce que entre guillemets d'une
certaine manière la civilisation
européenne
on sait le christianisme il n'y
appartiens mais on sait qu'il ya pas que
le christianisme
or quand on parle de la civilisation
islamique
on sait que l'islam lui appartient mais
comme les termes sont les mêmes on a
tendance à fusionner les deux pourquoi
je vous dis tout ça c'est parce que il
est évident que si l'islam est une loi
noah personnel une loi qui s'imposent
une loi qui gère les gestes quotidiens
la fusion dans le modèle européen peut
pas être complexe mais ça dépend sur
quoi ça dépend sur quoi par exemple dans
la common law donc dans le système du
droit britannique une partie de la
charia est tout à fait applicable
il ya des éléments de la charia qui ne
gêne absolument pas le droit le droit
britannique et qui pourrait être adopté
tel quel en europe va en france dans les
pays latins en général les éléments de
la charia ne sont absolument pas
compatible avec la loi française puisque
la charia notamment règle la question
des héritages des mariages or tout ça
c'est du domaine de l'état
donc si effectivement l'islam est une
loi bien il ya une multitude d'éléments
non compatit si elle n'est qu'un culte
et qu'une fois il a absolument aucun
problème et je ne pouvais pas faire un
prix de groupe
vous ne pouvez pas dire globalement les
musulmans sont adhèrent plus tôt à
l'idée que c'est une loi globale ou
alors globalement les musulmans a
déraillé que c'est un culte
les choses sont floues les choses sont
mixtes et ya pas une seule définition
l'autre élément dernier exemple dernier
la dernière précision qui parle qui
n'est pas inintéressante à préciser
c'est que depuis le 19e siècle et même
en turquie afin de remplir ottoman dès
le xviiie siècle
on a eu une multitude de phénomènes de
sécularisation
alors c'est vrai que nous en europe
notamment depuis le point du français en
fait pour nous les pays musulmans ne
peuvent pas se séculariser c'est une
espèce de une espèce de principe qu'on a
en tête un principe analytique on a en
tête
l'islam ne permet pas la sécularisation
or depuis le 19 18e siècle on a vu
notamment dans l'empiré ottoman 2d fun
extrêmement profond de sécularisation
qu'est ce que je veux dire les sultans
calife ottoman à partir du xviiie siècle
et notamment sur l'allemagne le
magnifique ont voulu prendre la main
notamment sur le droit le droit d
héritage et le droit familial et donc
ils se sont ingérées dans la charia pour
imposer un droit qui serait un droit
politique
un droit étatique contestant les
tribunaux cha rien et donc ça signifie
que depuis le xviiie siècle dans
quasiment tous les pays musulmans
on a eu un phénomène de concurrence
entre la charia tel qu'on l'imaginé
religieuse dont les jus les jugements
sont rendus par des parts dire tradi
c'est-à-dire par des par des juges de
sharjah et des tribunaux civils laïque
qui pénétrait dans le droit religieux et
qui était en train de lui prendre du de
le capter de l'usure paix sur des pans
entiers de la juridiction religieuse
c'est pour ça que lorsque la
colonisation c'est a interrompu lorsque
le monde musulman a été décolonisée en
fait le monde musulman avait déjà été
habitué à des pratiques extrêmement
profond de sécularisation et c'est après
les indépendances dans les années 50-60
que
pays musulmans ont adopté quasiment
massivement des pratiques de des
religieux aux isation j'ai pas voulu
fournir de oi de sécularisation de
laïcisation de leur législation
notamment sur la question de l'apostasié
il n'y a quasiment aucun pays musulman
qui condamne de fait
l'apostasié au meurtre un gars qui en
arabie saoudite dans les autres pays la
peau stasi est interdite
mais en réalité elle n'est plus condamné
à mort contrairement à ce qu'on dit il
ya que en arabie saudite et encore c'est
en train de changer
donc vous voyez que on est dans des
mondes qui ont vécu des phénomènes qui
peuvent plein proulx sera projeté de des
phénomènes européen mais qu'est-ce qui a
fait que ces phénomènes de
sécularisation et de laïcisation qui qui
est allé très loin dans certains pays
musulmans
comment se fait-il qu'on a l'impression
de le voir contesté depuis 20-30 ans
parce qu'on appelle les islamistes ou ce
qu'on appelle les salafis etc
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien en fait
vous êtes multitude de groupes à
tendance politique marqué par évidemment
le fait religieux en fait estime que la
seule manière de voir renaître le monde
musulman le monde arabe en général
la seule manière c'est de faire de
réimposer un islam épuré un islam qui
serait débarrassée de ses pratiques de
sécularisation qui sont pourtant elle
même d'origine musulmane dire que la
plupart des pratiques de sécularisation
ne sont pas liées à la colonisation
la plupart ça veut dire qu'elles sont
autochtones dire que les musulmans eux
mêmes ont tout à fait été capable de
processus de laïcisation mais les
groupes qu'on appelle islamistes eux
prétendent que la colonisation le déclin
du monde
musulmans vient en fait de ces pratiques
et donc il faut des sécularisée il faut
des laïcisé pour retrouver une puissance
politique militaire et social voyez que
on est face à des conflits de faux
surtout celles issues d'accords donc
vous venez de dire qu'il ya une
compatible une compatibilité possible
entre entre l'islam en tant que religion
et et la république et petites questions
complémentaires et et rapide est-ce
possible d'organiser le culte musulman
en france en se coupant totalement des
influences étrangères notamment
saoudiennes et turcs
alors aujourd'hui en france les pays les
plus influents sur l'organisation ou
l'islam c'est l'algérie et la tunisie
c'est pas la turquie c'est encore -
l'arabie saoudite la turquie a une
influence notamment dans l'islam
alsacien mais sur l'ensemble du
territoire dans les grandes structures
qui composent le conseil français du
culte musulman se sont en général plutôt
des algériens plutôt des tunisiens c'est
ce qu'on appelle un islam consulaires
c'est un islam l'islam des consuls à
l'islam des ambassades finalement des
ambassades algériennes et tunisiennes
installées en france alors toutes les
influences extérieures ne sont pas ne
sont pas problématiques
disons qu'il est évident que pour
l'éclosion d'un islam totalement
français et totalement totalement
intégré à la république il faut
évidemment limité ses influences
extérieures
mais dès lors qu'une influence
extérieure elle est faite par des
marocains des algériens des tunisiens
qui certes ont des liens politiques avec
les responsables de leur pays d'origine
donc là effectivement ça c'est gênant
mais l'islam maghrébin globalement ne
pose pas de difficulté
notamment vis à vis de la violence la
place des femmes
vous allez au maroc j'avais surtout en
tunisie même en algérie la place des
femmes pose pas de problème
il ya encore des traces encore du chemin
à parcourir enfin en france aussi donc
vous voyez c'est pas parce que l'islam
français très influencé par l'islam
maghrébin que c'est une catastrophe
donc ça c'est un premier point deuxième
point c'est l' influence du wahhabisme
donc l'eau à bize et cette structure de
pensée de religiosité d'origine arabe
arabe saoudienne qui date du xviiie
siècle et qui a longtemps été accompagné
dans sa prédication de courant unitaire
dans les camps jihadistes
depuis les années 50
le wahhabisme parce qu'il est dominé par
les saoudiens a renoncé au janis alors
évidemment temps en temps on a des
familles princières d'arabie saoudite
qui a encore des liens qui ont encore
des liens avec des mouvements des
mouvances militaire ou 80
mais globalement depuis cinq six ans on
sent que l'arabie saudite prend ses
distances avec tous ces mouvements là et
se gardent trop d'ambiguïtés il ya
encore des en ligne le qatar les émirats
sont encore très ambiguës
mais il ya un mouvement qui éloigne tous
ces pays un lent mouvement qui est loin
de tous ces pays de dimension purement
militaire militante de l'islam au il est
clair aujourd'hui que ça n'est pas
l'arabie saudite qui finance les
mosquées françaises à tous les rapports
traque fin tous les rapports au tour du
ministère de l'intérieur autour du
financement des mosquées
quant à donner à peu près le même
chiffre on est entre 4 et 8 millions par
an qui sont donnés par le qatar ou par
larbi entre 4 et 5 millions d'euros par
an donc il est clair il ya quatre ou
cinq millions d'euros par an vous
financez pas deux mille mosquées ou
mimos kansas et sous financée
ce sont des projets culturels donc le
financement l'islam de france
aujourd'hui il est assuré par des
musulmans français
ou par des musulmans qui ont la double
nationalité mais piétine double
nationalité en général maghrébine donc
voyez
voilà le financement extérieur est en
train d'être réglés ou il va se régler
dans l'est dans la décennie qui arrive à
propos de l'islam français
quel devrait être le rôle du conseil
musulman du conseil français du culte
musulman dans un colloque de les formes
l'islam en france étant donné qu'il est
fruit d'une volonté de l'état est
imposée par le haut
on peut se demander s'il est capable de
s'imposer à la communauté musulmane de
france où j'ai continuera à manquer de
crédibilité et de représentativité
quelle est la solution peut-il
participer à une forme d'adaptation de
l'islam à la france qui est une idée
qu'on voit ça souvent dans les médias
ou alors il n'a pas été formé pour ça
quand il a été créé d'abord on a lancé
l'idée en 94 elle s'est vraiment incarné
en 2003 lorsque le conseil français du
culte musulman a été créé l'objectif
c'était pas d'influencé l'islam
l'objectif c'était de créer des liens
institutionnels entre ministère de
l'intérieur et les communautés
musulmanes
c'était de pouvoir gérer les questions
de halal de pouvoir gérer aussi parfois
la question des formation d'imams
d'avoir du renseignement de terrain aux
prélats pour la police
voilà c'était de faire une interface une
interface institutionnelles entre la
république et les communautés musulmanes
le cfcm a jamais été identifiés formaté
pour opérer une réforme théologique
morale religieuse de l'islam de france
c'est pour ça que notamment depuis trois
quatre cinq ans a été créé la fondation
de l'islam de france la fondation de
l'islam de france elle
effectivement elle a été tournée avec le
soutien financier la république
aéroports de paris et la sncf je crois
elle a été fondée dans le but de faire
revivre ce qu'on appelle parfois l'islam
des lumières lice
homme des lumières c'est un islam qui
datent du à peu près du 9ème siècle qui
est un islam qui se fonde sur le
dialogue curieuse sur le dialogue
philosophique qui se fonde sur l' usage
de la raison et qui se fonde aussi sur
la pratique de la mystique et de la
spiritualité notamment une forte
influence souffle voilà la fondation de
l'islam de france est donc un très bel
outil qui n'a pas brûlé but de réformer
l'islam
pas du tout mais qui a pour but de faire
émerger dans l'islam de france des
structures et des mémoires rationnelle
philosophique et spirituelle de l'islam
c'est à dire que on n'invente pas un
nouvel islam ont fait valoir les
périodes historiques brillante
dialoguant de l'histoire de l'islam
voyez ce n'est pas une invention c'est
pas une réforme de l'islam
c'est une redécouverte et des tentatives
de re découverte et de remise à
l'honneur deux périodes marquées par ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une certaine
forme de tolérance qu'on peut appeler le
pas une ouverture sur la philosophie la
raison et ses actions est donc là où la
formation pauliste l'un de france est
une institution vraiment très
intéressante c'est que on ne réinvente
pas l'islam on en montre les aspects les
plus brillants et les plus compatibles
avec l'histoire de france
alors évidemment il ya donc deux deux
structures la structure institutionnelle
le cfcm est d'une certaine manière la
structure philosophiques et théologiques
la formation de l'islam de france
mais le problème c'est qu'une fois qu'on
a dit ça allait les gens sont pas
obligés d'adhérer
de même qu'il est évident que si la
république française impose et
d'éclairage et des prêtres jure heures
comme ça quelqu'un en 92-93 1792 et ses
sandales en a 13 en tant que chrétien je
sais pas obligés d'adhérer un prêtre
jure heures et c'est donc il est évident
que le fait que ces transformations ou
en tout cas
cette mise en valeur parts de la tête
sert parts de la république crée une
ambiguïté créé méfiance qu'on peut
éventuellement comprendre donc que
faut-il faire bat déjà à il faut pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain c'est à
dire que le cfcm existe il a des défauts
mais il existe la fondation de l'islam
de france existe elle fait un beau
travail
alors oui elle est peut-être peu
représentative mais au moins elle fait
le travail d'adaptation en tout cas de
démonstration que la pensée islamique et
la pensée européenne et française sont
tout à fait compatibles
donc c'est baba ce que les uns ne sont
pas le cfcm mais n'est pas appréciée des
musulmans ou de la majorité des
musulmans et parce que la formation du
slam de france ne reflète pas l'ensemble
des musulmans que il faut jeter ces deux
institutions on est obligé de les garder
on est obligé de les faire vivre
et voilà espérer que les choses dans
cinq six dix ans s'améliore danse
anciens évidemment ça ne peut pas
arriver
7 cette influence de ces deux
institutions ne peut pas pénétrer toutes
les sphères de la société et des
communautés musulmanes si au même moment
on a des discours médiatique qui sont
comment dire qu'ils sont agressifs c'est
sûr ça va pas aider d'accord donc on
vient de le voir en france on traite
énormément de la question de l'islam
c'est une question qui semble parfois
hanter les médias les éditorialistes les
hommes politiques etc
et est-ce qu'on peut on peut qualifier
cela d'une obsession française notamment
pour éloigner l'opinion publique
d'autres problématiques plus sociale
économique et politique ou y at il
réellement un enjeu de taille à régler
et particulièrement dans notre pays sur
cette question
oui alors là votre première suggestion
moi je la partage
c'est à dire que quand tous les mois au
moment où les chiffres ducobu des
chiffres du chômage les chiffres de ceux
ci sont mauvais et que tous les mois on
trouve un nouveau scandale autour de
l'islam
je ne dis pas qu'il ya pas de scandale
si pas que ces scandales n'existe pas
mais à un moment le calendrier quand
même bien fait un bon ça c'est méchant
voilà je suis assez d'accord exclu
l'autre aspect c'est que en france
particulièrement peut-être plus que dans
tous les autres pays européens
historiquement l'islam a a longtemps été
voir toujours été un élément pour se
définir se définir nous mêmes
que sommes nous nous français que sommes
nous nous européens et il est clair que
les relations avec l'islam ont toujours
été historiquement en parallèle elle
avec la mise en place des définitions
des identités européennes une espèce de
mouvement pas à l'aise plus l'islam est
dangereux sur le plan militaire maritime
économique lui l'europe créé des
éléments de sa propre définition -
l'islam est dangereux plus l'identité
européenne est ouverte au sens où elle
se métisse plus facilement et on sent
bien qu'on est dans une de ces vagues
en ce moment tous ces débats qui avaient
l'ancien président sarkozy sur la
question de l'identité nationale
face à ces caractéristiques nous sommes
dans une période anxiogène d'une
certaine manière dans un selon la
tradition historique française parce que
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus d espace
géographique homogène finalement
l'europe par la colonisation s'est
mélangée avec des pays musulmans après
la décolonisation des pays musulmans où
les des musulmans sont
mélanger en france donc en fait ce qui
pendant longtemps pouvait être rassurant
chaque ace paszek civilisation chaque
mentalité avait son espace de plus 50
ans et plus possible ce qui crée quelque
chose donc chez eugène pour lui
l'identité que ce soit l'identité
française ou européenne
mais que ce soit aussi pour l'identité
des musulmans d'origine algérienne
d'origine tunisienne et c'est donc en
fait il ya une question de définition
tout le monde voudrait ça paraîtrait
plus simples que chacun ait un espace
homogène mais en réalité quand on
regarde l'histoire c'est assez drôle
l'homogénéité spatiale des deux univers
n'a quasiment jamais existé sauf quand
l'espagne a été conquise par les
royaumes du nord donc et qu'on a expulsé
les musulmans d'espagne au 16e siècle à
la fin du xvième siècle mais vient au
moment l'espagne s'homogénéise et donc
qu'il n'ya plus de musulmans en espagne
au même moment les balkans eux sont
conquis par empire ottoman donc en fait
on est sur une europe dans les réalités
historiques jeudi pas dans l'idéal que
chacun voudrait mettre en place mais
dans la réalité historique ya jamais eu
d espace homogène et on est depuis 60
ans depuis la la colonisation mais aussi
depuis les grandes périodes migratoires
mais dans un monde où les deux univers
en fait désormais ne font plus chacun
une civilisation à part en fait ils se
sont en partie mélanger via la
démographie et via la colonisation et ce
mélange peut paraître anxiogène d'où
toutes les questions autour de la
définition de ce qu'est l'identité
française
mais le problème c'est que on en a 50
ans au trot ces débats là merci par
rapport aux espaces
est-ce que les problématiques liées à
l'islam que l'on rencontre en france se
pose de la même manière chez nos voisins
européens
qu'est ce qui est similaire qu'est ce
qui est différent alors
la problématique du dia 10 du terrorisme
se pose de la même manière non seulement
chez nos voisins européens
mais même chez nos voisins de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée c'est à dire que
quand vous regardez le nombre de morts
fait par des djihadistes à 90% ils sont
musulmans
c'est à dire que la question djihadistes
c'est une question mondiale c'est pas
une question qui concerne que les coûts
fall que les chrétiens que les européens
donc c'est un une pratique générale
après donc voilà pour le djihadisme pour
la question de l'islam ou de l'islamisme
je ne sais pas quelle est quelle est
votre préférence sur les voeux il est
clair que ça n'est donc pas pareil on
est bien d'accord
là la gestion de cette question est
complètement différente
par exemple qu'il soit en allemagne ou
en angleterre van royen min on a dans
ces deux pays un rapport aux communautés
musulmanes qui complètement différente
pourquoi parce que en italie en france
la question de l'état l'état
centralisateur l'état jacobin et est
fondamentale
il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire il n'y a
pas de corps intermédiaires entre le
citoyen et l'état
or en allemagne la république fédérale
d'allemagne et dans le royaume uni qui
acceptent la common law le entre l'état
et le citoyen il y à une multitude de
corps intermédiaires que les citoyens se
choisissent eux-mêmes ma communauté
en angleterre et reconnu comme tel
pas forcément avec sa loi mais avec ses
coutumes
il ne choque personne en angleterre on
prête serment sur le coran plutôt que
sur la bi ou sur autre chose
dès lors que des gens se conçoivent
comment une communauté
ils ont droit à être reconnus comme tels
et c'est c'est un peu moins le cas en
allemagne
mais on va beaucoup plus loin dans ces
deux pays qu'en france si bien que la
caisse
islamistes ne se pose quasiment pas
quasiment l'idée qu' il y aurait des
communautés musulmanes qui
s'organiserait politiquement pour peser
dans le débat public pourrait venir
éventuellement modifier la
réglementation municipale sur les
piscines des machins le truc
et bien ça c'est ce que nous un peuple
en appel islamistes eh bien ça ne pose
aucun problème au royaume-uni que les
gens veulent voter pour un musulman qui
va changer les horaires de piscine
s'ils votent pour lui ça n'a aucune
influence tant mieux et ben tant mieux
c'est leur liberté et donc vous voyez
que du coup la question de la liberté
d'expression et notamment du rapport aux
fameuses caricatures
le rapport est complètement différent en
france que en allemagne ou en angleterre
en france
la liberté d'expression est en fait un
outil de contrôle politique aux mains de
l'état ç'a toujours été le cas
les gros politique qui menace la
république
on va considérer qu'ils sont les ennemis
là la liberté d'expression ça a
longtemps été le cas de l'église
catholique est donc en fait en france la
liberté d'expression la liberté de
caricaturer est une arme au service de
l'état contre des groupes constitués qui
au sein des deux pays sont en hostilité
vis-à-vis de la république en gros
l'église qui a tenu aujourd'hui on est
passé de l'église catholique aux
communautés musulmanes alors quand en
angleterre en angleterre la liberté
d'expression est une arme au service du
citoyen contre les abus de l'état
c'est complètement différent c'est
exactement le rapport inverse et donc le
citoyen est libre de s'exprimer et de
critiquer l'état parce que cette liberté
lui permet de se protéger de l'état et
donc la caricature
dès lors quel choc le citoyen elle n'est
pas la bienvenue
en revanche la caricature qui permet de
critiquer l'état elle est l'élève est
donc en angleterre on ne publiera donc
pas les caricatures du prophète
notamment parce que le citoyen ne les
approuve pas ça le choc et il suffit
même qu' une partie l'opinion publique
soit choqué pour qu'on considère que
c'est de la mauvaise liberté
d'expression alors qu'en france c'est au
contraire de la bonne liberté
d'expression avec en fait vous êtes
obligé sur ces toutes ces questions-là
d'interroger finalement ce qu'est la
france ce qu'est son système politique
et la manière donc définition de la
liberté d'expression d'accord merci
malheureusement c'est déjà la fin dans
sept de cette entrevue merci merci à
vous olivier hahn
pour cette entrevue qui fut
particulièrement intéressante et merci
au nom de scopeo pour nous avoir accordé
un peu de votre temps
ce fut très intéressant notamment pour
questionner certains préjugés et pour
préciser certaines questions qui sont
souvent posées dans le débat public sur
un thème qui agite régulièrement
l'actualité et maintenant je vais
laisser la parole à domicile qui
conclura cette entrevue mais également
vous remercier c'était tout à fait
intéressant et j'en profite pour
signaler à ceux qui nous écoutent que
c'est notre troisième entre des
politiques donc que yaël sont que tous
nos podcasts sont disponibles sur
youtube mais aussi spotify et une
opinion aussi des tribunes désarticulé
et dossier sur notre site que au point
merci beaucoup
[Musique]